PROFESSOR: How do we think
of the Born approximation?
Well, we can imagine a
diagrammatic expression
when we use propagators.
Propagators are things
that take a signal
and propagate it
in some direction.
So think of your scattering
center here, and, of course,
we were supposed
to look far away
but I don't have enough
room on the blackboard.
I'll take this point
to be far away.
And now what does it
say, this equation?
It says that the first Born
approximation, you get that r,
the incident wave.
The incident wave has reached r.
This is the incident wave of r.
So I will represent this as a
wave that reaches the point r.
That's the first term
on the right hand
side, a line reaching r.
Because a wave has come in
that direction and reached r.
On the other hand, this
is a little different.
What is the physical
interpretation of this term?
This is a wave that
reached r prime.
And this wave was
shaken by the potential
and created the source, as
if the potential of r prime
was a medium.
The wave reached r prime, shook
the potential, and then a wave
appeared that was propagated
by the propagator, the Green's
function.
It took it from r
prime, it took it to r.
So our interpretation
of this diagrammatically
is that another part
of the incoming wave
came here and got to
the point r prime.
At the point r
prime, it interacted
with the potential,
which is a medium,
and out came a wave
in the direction of r
and reached there.
And r prime is supposed
to be integrated.
But that's kind
of in the figure.
So this is the
zeroth order term,
this is the first order term,
wave that reaches r prime,
wave that reaches [INAUDIBLE].
Now I can include
the second term.
I could include
it in this diagram
but I would confuse things.
So let's draw another one.
[INAUDIBLE] thing
doesn't look the same.
I won't get them
to look the same.
Doesn't matter.
Here is r still, and what
is our second wave doing?
Our second wave, we
could put it here
and imagine that you have
here the e to the ikr.
So here you would have e to
the ik dot r double prime.
So the wave reaches the point
r double prime, which is here.
And from the point
r double prime,
it interacts with the medium--
that's that heavy dot--
and gets propagated
into r prime, which
is also inside the material.
So another wave,
and here is r prime.
And once it's
propagated into r prime,
it interacts with
the material u--
that's the heavy dot--
and gets propagated into r.
So that's the second
order Feynman diagram.
The zeroth order first, Feynman
diagram, the wave just reaches.
First order, the wave
comes, interacts once
with the potential, and
re-emits a wave over here.
Second order comes here,
interacts with the potential,
emits a wave, interacts
at another point,
emits another wave,
and gets to you.
That's a pictorial description
of a Born approximation, which
makes it intuitive,
makes it clear.
It is like Feynman diagrams of
field theory, in which you have
some set of initial state,
some set of final state,
and you sort of find the
ways the particles arrange
themselves.
If you have an electron
and a photon scattering,
you have an electron here and
a photon scattering, and then
photon and electron
out scattering.
What do they do?
And then Feynman method,
you think, OK, they
do all what they
can possibly do.
They get the photon, interacts
with electron, electron
propagates and
re-emits a photon,
or it may be that the
photon gets emitted first
and then the incoming
photon hits the other place
and it goes that way.
All these things can happen.
And here you have
all the ways in which
the waves can scatter
and re-scatter back
to reach the observer.
Basically, you're
finding all possible ways
the waves interact with
the medium and reach you.
And that's a very intuitive way.
You think of it,
there the material,
you're there, what do I get?
Well, you get the waves
that just hit you directly.
And then you get the waves that
hit the material and scatter
to you.
And then you get
the waves that hit
the material, scattered, hit
the material again, and then got
to you.
And then you get the waves
that did that several times.
A very nice, simple picture.
So that is the
Born approximation.
We can do one example.
Let's do one example.
And assume, simplify
this formula.
So we did this formula.
And if the potential is
not spherically symmetric,
you can't do more with it.
But if the potential is
spherically symmetric,
that first Born formula,
which is a very famous result,
admits simplification and you
can do some of the integral.
You can do the angular
part of the integral
because the potential is
spherically symmetric,
and you know how
things depend on angle.
So it's a nice thing to have a
boxed formula that already does
for you this calculation when
the potential is spherically
symmetric.
So if v of r is equal to v of r,
which is spherically symmetric,
we go back to that formula and
we would have f of k of theta,
we claim, we'll see if that
is true, minus 1 over 4 pi.
Now this u there, remember,
this u was just the scaling of v
in order to make the Schrodinger
equation look simple.
So that involves a factor
of 2 m over h bar squared.
You still have the cube r prime,
e to the minus i k dot r prime,
v of r prime.
So what is the intuition
of such formulas?
I think it's important
for you, maybe
you haven't seen
these formulas before,
if you look at the
formula like this.
What do you expect the
answer to depend on?
What is that integral
going to depend on?
Any opinion?
Well, it certainly will
depend on the potential,
but now if it's very symmetric,
I might as well delete that.
Is that right?
We said it's
spherically symmetric.
So it will depend
on the potential.
That's, of course, true.
But will it depend
on the vector k?
Yes, it better depend
on the vector k.
But all of the vector k
or some of the vector k?
It's good to think about that
before doing the integral.
Well, the interesting
thing is when
you have an integral in this
form in which this doesn't
depend on the direction
of r, this is our prime,
but in fact, you
see, there's nowhere
in this formula anything
to do with r and r prime.
This is an integral
all over space.
So in fact, I can also
delete now the primes,
integrate them
over all of space.
There's no r on the left
hand side, there's no r left,
so what for carrying primes?
No need for that.
Now what I want to explain here
is that this integral can only
depend on the magnitude
of the vector k.
Cannot depend on the
direction of the vector k.
And because it depends on the
magnitude of the vector k,
it only depends on theta,
which is what we wanted to say.
So if before, you write
For theta, you could have
asked, well, how do you know?
This interval can depend
on phi, k dependent on phi,
but no, this integral doesn't
depend on the direction of k.
And it doesn't because
you can choose your axis
to do this integral
whichever way you want.
This is a dummy
variable of integration.
So if vector K points
in this direction,
you could choose the z-axis
to go there, and that's it.
It's only going to depend on
the magnitude of that vector.
So that's an important
concept in here.
Oh, and you can
think it another way.
This answer, if I would have
put another vector k prime here
that is obtained by
rotation, think of k prime,
I put here k prime, which
is obtained by a rotation,
acted by a rotation matrix on
the vector, say, from the left.
Well, you would say, OK, if
it's acted by a rotation,
I could instead make the
rotation act on the vector r.
This potential doesn't
change on the rotations
and this measure is
invariant on the rotation.
So at the end of the
day, this integral
does not depend on
the rotation you did.
So bottom line,
this integral just
doesn't depend on
the direction of k,
and we can do it by putting k--
or saying k is
here and now making
it explicit by putting r prime
here and calling this angle
theta.
And we just do it.
So if we call it that
way, this integral
is, you have minus m
over 2 pi h squared,
and you have the
volume integral, which
is 2 pi for the phi integral.
So we'll have a theta and a phi
that you integrate with respect
to k, and the phi integral
will always give you 2 pi
and will leave the
theta integral here.
So 2 pi.
And the r integral
is r squared dr.
The theta integral in spherical
coordinates is v cos theta.
And you have here e to the
minus i length of this,
length of that, cosine
theta times v of r.
So things simplify even more.
So the 2 pis can [INAUDIBLE]
minus m over h squared.
The radial integral, it's 0 to
infinity, r squared vr, v of r,
and you have the
angular integral,
and that angular integral
is easily doable.
It's that and this.
You can [INAUDIBLE] cosine theta
u and just do the integral.
That integral gives you
2 sin of Kr over kr.
And our result, therefore,
is, you shouldn't confuse
the capital K with
the lowercase k, which
is the magnitude of the momentum
or the magnitude of the energy.
So we're done, basically.
And what do we have
for fk of theta?
We have minus 2m
over K h squared,
integral from 0 to infinity
of r, dr, one r got cancelled,
the k went out, r dr,
v of r, sine of Kr.
So the Fourier transform
got partially done.
And here, K, as you remember,
is 2 k sine theta over 2.
So there we get the Born
approximation simplified
as much as we could.
We couldn't do
much better anymore
without knowing what
the potential is.
But once you know
the potential, it
has become just the
simple integral.
So while the concepts that led
to this result are interesting,
and they involve
nice approximations,
by the time you have this
result, this is very useful.
You can put an arbitrary
potential v of r,
calculate the
integral, and out you
get the scattering amplitude.
So this is done, for example,
for Yukawa potential,
v of r minus 1 over r--
well, we will put the beta--
e to the minus mu r.
That's called a
Yukawa potential.
It's the kind of modification
of the electromagnetic potential
in the limit in which the
photon would acquire a mass.
That was sort of the
intuition of Yukawa.
If you see-- this has
units of [INAUDIBLE]
physically mass and h
bars and things like that.
But if you let this thing
go to 0, if mu goes to zero,
you recover coulomb potential.
So that's the relevance
of the Yukawa potential.
Yukawa invented it
while thinking of pions
and thinking of the forces
transmitted by pions, who
are light hadrons and strongly
interacting particles,
but with low mass,
relatively low mass
compared to a proton, one
fifth of it or even less,
maybe, one seventh, one eighth.
And then you would have
a potential of this for
and you can study
scattering when
you have this kind of formula.
So this is solved in many books.
It's also in the textbook,
and in this case, f of k,
the integral can
be done exactly.
You can plug v of r there.
And the answer is
that fk of theta
is equal to minus 2 m beta over
h squared mu squared plus K
squared.
And K squared would
be this quantity.
So there is a theta
dependence, and you
can look at this formula,
compare with the Coulomb k,
[? take ?] limits, plot it,
it's kind of interesting.
So it's easily done, and you
can play with many potentials.
All right, so we're
done with scattering.
Done like three lectures
and a half on this subject,
and I'm going to now turn into
a new subject, our last subject,
which is we're going
to try to explain
some of the basics of
identical particles.